I want to talk about uh something that's
really pressing that's unfolding in DC
right now which is the reauthor or a
vote on the fisa reform and
reauthorization act and as part of that
the reauthorization of something called
section
702 um which uh essentially allows the
government to surveil Communications
between American citizens and foreign
targets without a warrant
um and it seems like now after some
resistance a clean reauthorization of
that is unlikely to happen it they're
attaching it to the National Defense
authorization act which is kind of like
the the the mil the defense budget for
the year um and they're they're trying
to slip a more temporary extension into
that could you just tell us what is at
stake for Americans with this issue
right so we're not trying to
eliminate the fisa 702 program it was
established to allow our intelligence
agencies to spy on foreigners without a
warrant in order to qualify to be spied
on without a warrant you have to be
outside of the country and you have to
be not an American citizen if you're
inside the country or if you're an
American citizen outside of the country
you can't be spied on by this program
okay sounds great right but we've got
250,000 people on that list that we're
collecting information on and in the
process of collecting that information
if you talk to a business person in
France for instance you your emails and
stuff may get caught up in this data
collection well what they've been doing
is they go into this giant ball of you
know data and they put in your name they
can put in Zach's name and search it
without a warrant U without Reasonable
Suspicion or probable cause there's or
or any of those sort of uh thresholds
legal
thresholds not to investigate suspects
but to create suspects let's say that
you and Liz are at a protest and um they
developed some Nexus they say well we
think these protesters were inspired by
Russia okay um well we're just going to
run all the protesters names through
this database now even though the Intel
Community doesn't concede that they need
a warrant for this they've admitted that
they violated their own protocols
hundreds of thousands of times when they
search for us persons U data in this
hstack they say well it was created
legally so we don't need a warrant to go
search
it there are two proposals to
reauthorize this program by the way
there the only chance you ever get to
reform these programs is when they
expire so it's important that they do
expire occasionally and this one expires
in
January and in the Judiciary Committee
which Jim Jordan chairs and on which I
serve we've marked up a bill that would
require them to get a warrant it would
create uh criminal penalties for people
in the executive branch who abuse the
program because there's never any uh you
know culpability or or blowback for
anybody that's abused this program um
but this would create that so we've
created this Reform Bill and then the
Intel committee has created a bill which
is less than ideal it doesn't have a
warrant requirement it doesn't have many
of the reporting requirements back to
Congress that the Judiciary bill has and
in fact it expands their ability to
collect information to for instance uh
if you had free Wi-Fi at a cafe that
that service provider would be treated
like Google or Verizon now and they
would have to create a direct pipeline
to the Intel agencies for any of the
communications that go through that so
that you got two proposals out there and
we're running out of time so what
speaker Johnson has proposed and some
Senators have proposed oh let's just
keep the old program in place for a
little bit longer your basic
Congressional kicking the can down the
road exercise that's going to be uh
passing the Senate probably today unless
Mike Lee and ran Paul can stop it then
it comes to the house probably tomorrow
now an interesting thing here is I serve
on the rules committee and Chip Roy and
Ralph Norman do as well and we told the
powers to be uh We're Not Gonna we can't
go along with this so they couldn't um
pass a rule to combine the fisa program
with the ndaa that's how they're going
to try and get it through attach it to
must-pass legislation the National
Defense authorization act well we said
nope this shall not pass the rules
committee so they're going to try and do
this on suspension which and there's a
house rule that says if you want to
suspend all of our regular rules and
expedite something you need a two-thirds
vote of the house so this is going to be
interesting to see if they can get
effectively
290 uh people to vote for it yeah yeah
it is interesting because if you think
back to when a lot of Americans were
first into this with the Snowden
Revelations about a decade ago uh there
were some sort of you know lonely
dissenters to just rubber stamping this
stuff yourself among them some of the
other people you mentioned Rand Paul
Mike Lee uh some people on the
Democratic side of the aisle uh it does
seem as if now there's more resistance I
mean I assume some of that has to do
with the way fisa was used uh against
the Trump Administration do you feel
like there's the political Tides have
shifted uh somewhat to the advantage of
people who care about privacy and
government surveillance yeah the tides
haven't just shifted the stars have
aligned okay we've we've never had a
chairman of either the Intel committee
or the Judiciary Committee who made
reforming this program one of their
priorities um and so with Jim Jordan
we're very lucky to have him as the
chairman of this committee and this is
one of his
signature uh agendas is to get this
reformed because we have seen abuses
that have been used against the
president um president Trump so cons a
lot of conservatives have woken up to
the fact that this program is being used
against them um you have liberals who
are upset about the program obviously
the FBI is using this against black
lives matter as well um and we we know
that to be the case so you do have this
Coalition of the left and the right um
it used to be a coalition of maybe a
dozen people right like it was me and
Justin Amos and zo Lofgren and and Tulsi
gabard maybe uh who were concerned about
this and we used to come together and we
would offer amendments to try to fix
this in the funding bills we would try
to defund some of this stuff which is a
really blunt instrument it's a lot
easier to write legislation that affects
the laws than it is to just defund
something and they they would Pat us on
the head and say well you know we
appreciate the sentiment but this isn't
the time or place to to do what you're
doing and um you shouldn't be mucking
around with the funding but now is the
time in place the program is expiring
we've got a a chairman who's sympathetic
to the cause and um a lot of people a
lot more people on the left and the
right who are you know this reported out
of the Judiciary Committee 35-2 there
were only two denters and it was on the
Democrat side to the Judiciary fiser
Reform Bill hey thanks for watching that
clip from our new show just asking
questions you can watch another clip
here or the full episode here new
episodes drop every week so subscribe to
reent TV's YouTube channel to get
notified when that happens or to the
just asking questions podcast on Apple
Spotify or any other podcaster see you
next week